campus
all right so this is probably in uh Dojo
has been around since
1999.
um
this is the first video
uh or even information
where I'm prioritizing
the viewing public
particularly Aikido practitioners
and
secondarily
addressing your training okay
the video is on kihonawaza training
if you're a long time follower online
this should be known to you
so I'll only give the high highlights of
that bulk of information
so the first thing is kihon wazla
training is a type of training
it is technically ritual
it is not sparring
and it is not
a commodity
in a self-defense industry
that works through a if then modality or
a plug and play
self-defense
understanding meaning
when a guy grabs your wrist you do this
that is not true
they as rituals
from a pre-modern culture
in all likelihood
have their Origins not in martial
environments
but instead
have their Origins
in what we today would call religious
environments
in that they are
primarily geared towards
what Huxley has
called The Perennial philosophy
that I use that term because that's the
easiest Gateway for a modern person to
understand what is going on
but the primary goal purpose utility of
these rituals
was to give the practitioner
access to what I again first simplifying
reasons call the god mind or the second
mind
what Ian mcgilchrist calls the right
hemisphere in his book
the master and it's emissary
or more accurately defined
the experience of the world
which is what mind is the experience
of the world
once
the ego tripartite line or the first
mine
stops
these rituals were geared towards
a cessation of that egoic mind when Ian
mcgilchrist calls the less left
hemisphere
and the generation of that second mind
and then to ultimately have them
integrated or reconciled
this is the ancient oldest
Wellness system
that human beings have ever developed
and it is the only one that ever works
that is what these rituals are
but because
pre-modern cultures
work through
what we would call what epistemologist
would call a concentric epistemy the
very process by which the two minds are
reconciled
would go on
through various correspondences
and repeat
that same reconciliation process
so you would be able to do it
at what we would today call a psycho
physio physical level or what we might
today call a spiritual level
but you could also go on to do it at a
martial level
and because of the truth of its position
you would never ever do a martial
art
in any contradistinction to that truth
of the two minds that that would be
crazy no one would ever conceive of that
so as you fast forward through time that
is how you get Aikido that is how you
get Aikido kihonawaza
that was in place for o sensei
to utilize
and why you do not from his point of
view
Spar or compete
or try to fight with the Arts
that's the main goal that's the main
thing that's what you should be doing
again because of its concentric nature
it does not mean you cannot fight with
the art in fact
because of the concentric equivalency
the more sound
the integration of your God mind with
your egoic mind is the more sound your
martial art is marshally
and vice versa
but when you look at
it is that ritual
not a self-defense or a sparring
environment
you have to pull that out
so in that sense
you're not necessarily working on here's
what you do when somebody uh tries to
cut your head
and then you start arguing over who
would cut your head like that
do you understand
the beginning point is totally arbitrary
because the sole goal is
this integration
of the egoic mind and the god of mind
that's what you're after
so
what Aikido has done over the course of
very relatively short time
is that has been lost why because
culturally oh Sensei was at the end the
tail end of an age
where secular materialism and the
scientific epistemy established its
economic dominance
and the resultant of that is that the
art is understood materialistically
not metaphysically
and that's how you get into the little
debate that is going on in the Aikido
world all Aikido needs to be Marshall
Aikido is nothing about fighting and you
do see
do you get that
but no one can do what the founder did
so yesterday
I did a video with you and you are
working
uh on something that the general Aikido
rule does not understand what
so
why don't they understand what and how
would you understand better what quihon
waza is in light of what I just said so
I have Naga and UK
these were ritualistic manifestations
of the doubt of Yin and Yang
and you will
participate
in the ritual
in my integration
of
the god mind and the egoic mind
concentrically we will be in communion
at the
at that psycho physical level not just
externally your arm and I your arms
going down and I don't clash with your
arm
we are supposed to equally participate
in that communion
between the egoic mind and the god mind
your participation in that is not
choreography
that that's what some people saw the
video and saw choreography okay so they
imagined a bunch of ways that you could
have gotten out do you think
part of the reason for that is because
the the
consensual extent the concentric
extension
of the egoic mind and the god mind as it
applies to the art
as it has been negated the internal
aspect has disappeared from the art as
the art has been seen through secular
materialism there's only external
reconciliation of Yin and Yang but
pre-modern man would have an internal
reconciliation as well and that is not
always visible
on video to the eye that has never
experienced that sensation of your of
energy running throughout your entire
body and you can't go anywhere but where
you're being taken they they cannot see
it
my recommendation is you go to our
YouTube channel and look up the aiki
koku list and what to look for instead
is how their Center
is what is being manipulated first and
foremost and secondarily things like
their stance or their feet or their
limbs legs and arms and head the the
center like gets pulled out
so what I would like to do here
is uh demonstrate how
as a ritual there's only one place for
you to go
and it's not that you are choreographed
to go that way
and the choice really is between
the ideal goal which is participation in
the integration of the god mind and the
god mind
or
Do Your Own Thing ego at mine and pain
that that's the choice okay the pain can
sometimes show up
in uh locks at joints but most often at
full speed in you can't take the eukemi
you can't reconcile with the ground you
fall segmented do you see so as I
integrate the god mind and the egoic
mine there's some physiological aspects
that happen in in the Nugget uh yes
you'll you'll have a swelling or
pressure or whatever poetic expression
you want to use the chi will fill up the
midsection of the body
um and the heaviness will come over you
okay
um
but
your choice is to join me in that same
unifying centeredness
physiology which stems from
I don't want to point to my brain but it
stems from the integration of the two
minds
that's one choice
or to just have your Center moved with
your limbs going in other directions do
you understand that that that's that's
your only agency do you do you unify and
participate with me in the communion or
do you become a victim of the communion
that's the only agency there is okay so
uh
you must understand I think any viewer
would understand that as the momentum
and the inertia increases there would be
more uh resistance to radical changes in
direction do you guys understand that so
if she's coming full speed up and full
speed down
and forward it would be harder for her
to change to go rearward or to turn this
thing around you get it okay but it
doesn't matter I'm gonna exaggerate the
forces uh in the at slow speed it still
will not matter you'll see there's a
track
that you can be on
and there's not a track you can be off
okay so as kihon Wasa the initial energy
is prescribed so she's gonna do a strike
and it ends here we'll do it again
shomanucci the strike comes up and it
ends here so by
ritual prescription
that is what you have to do so there's
nothing you can change in the middle of
that do you understand because it's
ritually prescribed it's not sparring
okay
uh so as we come up right
and uh
I'll have her push push down on me go
ahead push be pushing keep pushing do
you see what's happening to her frame
maybe come over here
okay let's take me back up okay okay
here you are
so uh she she would turn up the
intensity go okay and what's happening
to you don't don't undo anything try to
lock your body let's give her more power
Chris
you're going to push down on her yes
okay okay she goes good do you see
what's happening to her body it's
turning you see that okay so uh I go
this way
and she goes down how does she go down
in this shape
do you see
so are you here if you pushes boom you
see it did it on her body because you
broke scent right okay I let it go down
and use that momentum to bring her hand
around
you see and bringing her hand around is
what lowers her shoulder okay there's
really no effort in it
he I follow her up
boom she comes down I'm moving out of
the way there's no effort in it at all
in the middle
we'll go slow okay
um
you have to not unlock it okay
uh she pushes push harder forward down
here cut down with your mind boom there
you go there's that little tilt I come
around all right got it
you're gonna finish the cut
got it okay I want you to uh
pull do you understand
okay go
so what am I doing I'm grounding I'm
grounding over here so I'm not holding
here like this again this is the
internal stuff you cannot see
this is supposed to be impossible right
in other words if she pulls the arm I'm
supposed to go like this
but here I'm just gonna grab
you see
that's it then
again all impossible
because there's no internal skills that
are visible
there's no
experience in the internal
so yesterday when your knees were
hurting that would be not internal
so again at full speed that would be
very hard because she's supposed to cut
down remember but it's not like your
arm's gonna go there because there's an
internal movement
that is happening
that's inside the centrifugal energy
that everyone knows and sees do you see
that and as in your body
there is enough resistance in the
movement of your mass
that that's what's actually making you
come around
okay so for example
uh don't add any energy or bring you
around
add the energy that way
faster because her energy is generating
more Force at the point of contact
so I do that with your mass
here's your mass I'm going to move your
mass I ground your mass
and it brings the body around
but not by me
doing a mad amount of strength on your
joint
bye
so if we go slow again
she has to finish the cut but it doesn't
matter you can pull you can pull it's
still going to come around this way as I
ground
okay now actually
that's what she's supposed to do in the
keyhon per prescription she resists
um
I could use those same skills
do you see
uh I'll just focus on this hat
okay so imagine I have this I have this
joint locked and keep her hand from
posting
okay I'll take off the joint log
and again
as she tries to stand up
that's internalized and you see all it
does is make her go off balance so you
want to try to get up
get up all the way
go
okay so what I do in the technique
though is when I feel her resistance to
the Eco Ura instead of shoving it down
I go one more Tank on
and this Push Pull again so if you if
the push pull let's do that so she's
here
it's the same thing here's an internal
pulling like you had on the first one
and uh internal
pushing so you're gonna push your hand
same thing
just move the center okay it's not here
in the joint it's in the body
but what I'm going to do instead is
leave it there
and come around to here
that's it
then I attack with rokio
but she's gonna counter another
prescription in Nico so stay there if
she doesn't counter a hover
Roku
she's gonna counter rokio
by dipping her elbow under and that
walks her into Nico again go back
just like I don't she posts there I
would not want to do the ritual like
this
go
instead I should post stairs here trying
to shove her down with the kill or do I
come around
instead of trying to shove her down with
rokio as she comes around and counters I
take the Ninja
okay
we'll look at the Nico
she comes around so what if she did not
come around
and put herself in ethio
she's in rokio the technique's done
so she does counter
she's here
okay
now why does she go from here to there
so let's just look
okay look at my body
this is not here this is there
as long as she stays here in the
communion of Center to Center this does
not hurt because this was a counter
but
stand up you can tap when you don't like
it go go yeah go ahead uh okay go back
pull out
you see uh push in
good push in here because good I'm not
I'm not gonna sit here and go I'm not
doing that it's all grounded
okay go backwards
you're gonna There Is No Escape it's
just do you participate
Center to Center communion
this not your brain
spirit Spirit
communion or not that's your agency
that's it okay so when I now move you I
am Unified
you are unified or you're not you see
that so I move her
she moves as a unit again stand up until
you don't want to yeah you see go
backwards until you don't want to go
forward till you don't want to you see
come in till you don't want to
there's not a choice there okay
now
at the same time why does the technique
now attack the wrist again instead of
the elbow
because the elbow's down it's not
vulnerable it's not open this this only
happens in in Aikido La La Land okay you
cannot do that so what I want you to do
is be in the communion and realize you
if you're in it
and you're working from your Center
and you're in my Center this is a
stalemate
okay so I should not be able to come to
you either you see I should not be able
to can't you you she's not as vulnerable
as people think okay so again
uh you do it Nico we're just here she
throws me this ah you see that's me not
participating it but my whole body is
Unified I let her energy come into my
Center go and I move as a unit okay I I
can feel like this
do you see
and uh
mount
I'll uh wait
mom
I'm in her Center
again you keep going I'm not doing
anything
so it's not it's only vulnerable from
the non-communion state
but here if you got thrown into
communion State I should not feel
let me show it I should not feel this
right it's relaxed
and extended
not means this is not there you see
relax and extend it got it got it feel
my Center
there's no that's I would never do that
I might try once and then go no that's
not gonna work you stronger than me
so instead I go around the contention
point the neutral point it's over here
you see and then the elbows are
available there's no support
do you see
and I'm going to make a smaller Circle
so that arm helps me okay so if I do
equal again
it won't we'll do all that again
but my smaller circle is going to go
this way
you see and again
uh you land
in the technique do you see that yeah
it's not here
and then I go here so let's go back
your counter here right we're back here
your countered here
allows me to go around it
and we're going to do the same thing
okay so we'll do uh
pull your arm out
okay take that energy pull your arm out
and then what did it do what do you
notice now about the final pin it's
tighter it's tighter okay it all got
tighter so you land immediately in the
dislocation
to beat
and
co-participate in
this egoic God mind integration
concentrically is
that pressurized hotter
is conjoined with my pressurized heart
okay and what you notice is
while I can't go anywhere
the technique does not hurt
okay so imagine for any number of
reasons
you tried to go up or out or in you see
that it just hurts right
um and you're gonna go anyways okay
here's the thing
when
the egoic mind and the god mind are not
integrated the center is not Unified
my own nor mine to yours okay and that
will always lead
to all those things
uh that generate pain or crashing on
your end
you're still gonna go do you see but how
you experience the nagawaza as UK is
entirely different as different as a
human being who experiences work
solely from the egoic mind that's one
day at work
and another person in the same job doing
the same exact thing can integrate the
god mind and the egoic mind they have an
entirely different experience at work
okay so when we go what I am feeling for
and in yesterday's class
is
that egoic mind okay what how can I feel
it I feel your Center separating from
mine do you see that oh I feel
that the center to Center connection is
one way my way to you okay so uh for
example we're back on yesterday's
training okay and there was a time
when you came in this way do you see
that that is a disconnect from the arm
so I told you you would not be able to
come that way because the arm cutting
down
and you'll see
it so you fell out of the ritual right
so
again
boom we're in it and you should feel for
my Center
around
home unify
good
okay
and none of that pain ever right
and then as you get better we do it
faster faster and harder harder faster
harder harder okay
all right you're going to you're trying
here so if if you don't start countering
right away I'm gonna get it you
understand so it shouldn't be here and
then he goes this dude should already be
countering once he feels that that's
that's the opening though okay
this is the opening in rokio
you see if I get to here and there no
you're done okay so as you feel the the
pressure coming off and around you're
already around trying to get out of Road
and then I allow it
as he's trying to get out of it I don't
hold him here because I already lost
this technique right go ahead and keep
going I'm not gonna get Roku
but I will get Nico by releasing and
coming in now we're on your point
when I take your Center over there
it's not a material thing which means
Center here in space
Center needs to go there in space
let's push it
it's an energetic thing so I don't have
to take your forearm here you feel that
and you're pushing the forearm
here connected in in our body
in our body so I'm over the top you see
but I'm holding the lock in place and
that's what moves
so I'm in the hand grip and that's what
it means
not this you're going to overpower me
you're stronger than me you see right in
your body
so resist the temptation to do the old
work hey
okay so let's repeat something that I
just said
um oftentimes in Aikido they'll talk
about the center to Center there is a
center to Center okay
uh or being centered oh yes but
it's not that
the center to Center relationship is
first a part a mutual participation in a
Reconciliation of the egoic mind and the
god mind okay without that there is no
Center to center that is why modern
aikido's choreograph you see UK goes
wherever the tech the the culture tells
them to go in this version you saw it
don't it doesn't matter why she wants to
do right and again I point out that at
full speed all those little things that
she could have tried you're not tribals
they're less triable okay but even at
slow speed it did not work do you see
um
the center to Center relationship is
more of a manifestation
of the original
communion between the egoic mind and the
god mind okay same goes with my Center
as a single person
my centeredness is a consequence of the
original
uh communion not it's not you you can
think all you want on your Center you
can imagine all you want on your Center
you can intend all you want those are
all intellectual processes they are all
part of the egoic mine and they will
keep you your ego with mind functioning
and they will not be able thereby to
manifest the god mind and therefore you
do not have the original communion and
so you do not have the subsequent
concentric communions do you understand
okay so it it is not in the body the
body
The Body Center to Center or your Center
to your movement all that is is uh
a coincident it's just a coincidence
okay that that's all it is a concentric
Coincidence of the original communion
okay
um
let us watch a couple things okay so uh
let me have a southern August okay
all right
uh so if my Aikido if my kihon Wasa is a
vessel in which a ritualistic vessel in
which I cultivate that communion skill
do you see that then thereby
we are in various phases of skill
cultivation do you get that okay okay so
as I mentioned last time I can turn it
up very very fast with Ronin and he will
maintain his own reconciliation or his
own communion of his God mine and his
egoic mind it'll manifest it Center and
I never throw his his Center without him
connecting and remaining connected to my
Center you see uh but if I think if we
were to turn it up you would lose
the communion of the two minds the
center would go away and now I'm
throwing your Center you're not
connected to my Center okay
um so there's skills to it okay which
means we're at different levels to it
all right so as we go yeah yeah you're
gonna go so even that to me is a sign of
it do you see
um and we come around
and um you can see what you did already
is you put your hand in the technique
how about go back
we're here and I came around and you put
your hand in the technique do you see
that
um why
that was the culture culture
no no it's an egoic tendency you want
your control
and the scary part
of having your center from is you're not
in control you're not in control and so
your egoic mind will start to function
it will not cease that God mind will not
be integrated and you will lose your
Center that's that's what happens okay
so there is a relationship between the
communion of the first mind and the
second mind the egoic mind and the god
of mine
if with the cessation and the
reconciliation and the absence of fear
okay
um which is why as you increase the
intensity the quality of the communion
of the two minds is increased because
increased intensity has a propensity to
generate more self-preservation more
fear Okay so
and if you paid attention
when you did all of your uh self-control
there's a hell of a lot of tension in
your arm
used a lot of guarding uh to help you
feel safe by disconnecting okay and
where do you think that what do you
think that muscle tension is going to do
to the to the joints
it's going to make it hurt okay so uh I
would like for you to flex your muscles
you see I'm not changing anything you
change the value of the technique you
see and as the technique goes
you're going to become uh disconnected
out of communion and I'm still gonna
move your Center but your limbs will now
add resistance to the Joint law okay do
you see okay so as I come you see you're
still trying to get out of it and I'm
telling you right now there's no there's
no lock on you there's actually no lock
on you you just relax you see relax
don't change the shape though you're
like I'll relax if I put my arm my way
just relax right there hey
all your body all your body don't change
the shape
don't change the shape
keep relaxing
see I'm like a horse whisperer now you
see I I put a little uh ribbon on your
back you're getting used to it you see
oh hey easy whoa whoa
get right and then I I like I touched
your back I touch your back with the
blanket you've seen this horse whisper
screen and you see there's no pain you
see that okay I'm gonna get up on one
Stirrup there's no this does not change
the angle vein
Let It Go
good there you go
hey I'm doing here I'm not changing I'm
not changing the shape
you see but it was all killing you
before
and as it killed you before the center
to Center connection drops hi Daisy yes
and so and as I proceed with the
technique
um for example
uh just hold yourself still don't go
okay
I thought you're not gonna go so she's
still not going here because that hand
is not where I'm taking you and it hurt
more okay pay attention because we're
still going this way
so just go back
gear want to say yourself still well
where are we going okay so what should
you do go that way let's not go that way
still went that way do you think let it
hurt go back
same thing there's no pain right here
there's not going to be any pain
throughout the whole thing because
you're going to maintain that
relationship
by being connected to your Center
my Center
and we move together when you feel me
move you
because you're in in the ritual so I
move you there you go and relax because
there's no need for that didn't change
but you tensed up and that when it's
made it hurt okay there's no pain at all
yet irretense right here again
the arm
does not change wash your arm watch your
arm watch your arm you were all relaxed
we're just going to do this stop it
doesn't tip doesn't tense
uh Comes This Way no tension bring your
elbow back down that's tension okay do
you see yes so you go with the technique
again
uh go back rewind the film rewind the
film that means reverse there you are
okay so here we are and again I am not
telling her
to choreograph herself into the
technique I am telling her to
participate in the communion
meaning when I go like this
uh drop your elbow resist it she's it
just hurts do you see and I move she
moves do you see that stand up
you see go forward
go out
you see I'm not telling her to
choreograph what I need her to do I'm
telling her participate in the communion
relax
take away everything you just felt it's
not really on
taking them all away
there you go
cool and again when I come to
come to not telling her push your elbow
there because I can't put her elbow
there do you understand and just like I
I'm going to
uh take advantage of a very very small
circle she she cannot
she cannot stop that Circle do you see
I'm telling you to to participate in the
communion so as you feel your whole body
move you let it move come back that was
ahead of me
you're like surfing with a jet ski and
you took off you took away from the wave
okay so you uh stay in the community
hold on I'm gonna now touch your Center
and you're gonna let me do you
understand hey
don't don't go in and out
feel that
I'm making small circles
don't no you're making circles now you
let me move your Center
now you move your Center you see how
it's different okay I'm going to move
your Center and you don't freak out when
I move your Center hi so here we go
good okay
in this relationship we're in now we
keep this relationship
all the way down you don't run away at
the bottom okay you keep this
relationship hey
there you go
same thing here don't lay down don't go
passive feel feel for me feel for me let
me touch that Center
stay in that communion
then again I don't want you to tap out
in relation to pain you tap out in
relation to mechanics so if you can tell
Sensei Center is gonna crush me if he
wants that that's time to tap
okay do you understand yes okay so here
you had two experiences of the same
exact movements one hurt a hell of a lot
and one did not hurt at all do you get
it now you have to do that at the speed
of life not with The Horse Whisperer
get in you there okay but you can in
that portion see that as soon as your
Center was touched and was be moved
your ego mind went whoops up
stop okay and then you got disconnected
from your Center and now I'm just moving
your Center and everything you're doing
with your limbs is now feeding the force
engine that I'm using okay you're still
gonna be moved it's more well what's
your experience it would be like this
you can you can follow the will of God
or you can
feel the rest of God if you go where
God's taking you it's not bad if you
resist where God's taking you it's bad
okay it's the same thing you're gonna go
but how you go
Isa is from UK's point of view are you
participating in the communion okay
which is not choreography okay
sometimes uh
you'll have a Meteo Cami
he goes great Union Place camera
and your hair
you see and he goes and I'm like ah and
usually this guy taps and then he kind
of eases up to me
that is not Jiu Jitsu okay
the top at the end is a recognizing of
kokiroyoku so once you can tell kokidoku
is there
that's why I tap I'm not tapping because
he's gonna break my arm because
what I'm supposed to do as uke is
reconcile if you get and tapping is
means I'm not going to reconcile this
y'all you please stop it that's to me
that's not kihon waza that might be
something you do in in sparring but not
in kilo okay okay so as he comes around
for example the only reason that I'm
here and I have to tap is because I'm
not following the yin space you see I'm
here staying here okay and so he he's
gonna go and I'm like
but they if you look at it
I can go pay attention we'll just we'll
just relax
open up the technique so the camera can
see here is my Yin space
you see so he goes back on the lock
I'm underneath it
press it down as hard as you can
bow as much as you want
there's no lock here
the lock
is solely here because I stayed here
so if he tries to slam me down here and
I come under he's gonna lose
and I'll have the counter
I don't want to do that in the yin yon
reconciling reconciling ritual sparring
okay this is not consensually martial
that ukemi nor that variant
so what he does instead
is he does not rely upon my mooc my call
for mercy
he takes the kazishi do you see it's
he's going to keep taking my balance
precisely because I can counter this
under the bottom so he takes my balance
and what some of you are doing as you
get your Center taken is you just take a
dive he goes and you hear whoa
okay and you're kind of
Folly but he wants to go
more
and you're like no well
learning again
if he happens to go more then you have
to move more you see
but
if you understand
the participation in the communion
you don't have to do that fall
so there was the the counter to ikyo
okay and then comes the counter
to rokio and then he's going to do the
movement and I'll just walk around
counter walk around keep going dude
counter counter
and I am actually using
his Center to help me his Center go lose
me
counter counter
so watch your uh
getting projected then diving because
now you're out of participation in the
communion
okay